Alors...
Apparement, y a un gros malentendu sur ma sentence.
Parce qu'on me parle de me couper la tête.
Mais bon, on va régler ça en discutant.
C'est qu'une méprise.
Les amis !
Merci d'être venu.
Aelys est devenu complètement fou, il veut me couper la tête !
Ah non, mais ils sont au courant.
C'est même, plus ou moins, leur idée.
Quoi ?
Ouais.
Tout le monde pense que tu es un connard.
Par exactement...
Vous l'avez pas dit ?
Pas exactement dans ces termes.
Ah si !
Si, connard.
T'as pas dit "connard" ?
Alors, moi, j'ai peut-être dit "connard".
Mais c'est parce que tu écoutes très peu.
Bande de petits bâtards.
On avait demandé du changement.
Dans le Royaume.
Et bah c'est ça !
Là, il est vivant et ça va changer en il est mort.
Mais on avait aussi dit qu'on ne voulait pas qu'il souffre.
Oui !
Ah mais moi, au départ, je voulais l'écarteler.
A côté de ça, lui couper la tête c'est mignon.
Et puis détendez-vous, hein.
On va faire ça gaiment !
On va inviter tous les villageois à voir le spectacle.
Y aura des petits stands de bouffe !
A boire.
Des...
Comment ça s'appelle là, le truc à base de maïs ?
Du pop corn.
Voilà ! Oh faut que je le note ça !
Bon, ça va être super !
Bon moi je file, je vais préparer tout ça.
A plus tard !
Vous m'avez condamné à mort !
J'ai dit "changement".
Il a interprété, il est devenu fou !
Mais pourquoi vous demandez du changement ?
Vous êtes pas suffisamment heureux et épanouie avec moi ?
Non...
Heureux c'est pas le mot, non.
Tu écoutes très peu.
Hein ?
Tu écoutes...
Sérieusement, est-ce qu'il y a un de vos projets que j'ai pas soutenu ?
Ma passion pour le théâtre, par exemple.
C'est faut Yorel ! C'est pas vrai !
Tu mens !
Y a pas plus tard que quelques jours, j'ai soutenu une super pièce là.
C'était un enfant qui se faisait enlever par des loups.
Et dévorer par un ours.
J'ai adoré ! C'était génial ça !
C'était pas une pièce, c'était vrai.
Tu veux dire que le vieux monsieur là...
C'était son père !
Ah ouais ? Putain, la vache.
Je me disais, il était vachement investi et tout.
Tu vois, tu écoutes peu !
Quoi ?
Non ! Là c'est un piège !
Parce que j'étais avec Yorel !
C'est comme quand je te parle du droit des femmes.
Mais j'adore les femmes, Clarisse !
J'adore ! C'est ce que je préfère après le poulet !
Tout ce que vous faites, c'est génial !
Les potages.
Les condiments autour !
La broderie !
Vous faites des trucs...
Et puis, les enfants, Clarisse !
C'est vous, hein.
C'est pas nous.
C'est vous, les enfants.
Tu lasserais une femme avoir le pouvoir ?
Mais voilà !
Mais vous êtes super marrantes, en plus !
Vous arrivez à me faire des blagues.
Oh merci Clarisse. Ça faisait longtemps que j'avais pas rigolé.
Bon, les amis.
Moi, je veux pas mourir ici, d'accord ?
Faut pas me laisser là.
Faites-moi sortir d'ici.
On est une famille !
Allez-y ! Partez !
Moi je m'en fous, j'ai un plan !
Oh oui, oui, oui !
Daniel, il a un plan.
Ah ! Belyr !
Tu voulais me voir ?
Aelys...
Je voulais pas en arriver là mais tu ne me laisses pas le choix.
Je te défie...
En duel judiciaire.
C'est la loi.
Et j'ai parfaitement le droit de demander ce duel.
Et si je gagne...
Je serais libre.
Alors, oui. C'est vrai mais c'était la loi.
Parce que je l'ai faite changer.
Nouveau seigneur, nouvelles règles.
Non, maintenant, les duels, ça se passent avec des bûcher.
On prend les deux duellistes...
On les jette dans le feu...
Et celui qui survit, il a gagné.
C'est plus... dragon !
Toujours intéressé ?
Je te laisse réfléchir.
C'est ça...
Fais le malin.
Monsieur je-brûle-pas-dans-le-feu !
Tu sais ce qui brûle pas ?
Le sourire d'un enfant !
Ok. Donc, soit je meurs par le feu.
Soit je meurs par l'épée.
Mais pour l'instant, le plan c'est que je meurs.
Pour lui couper la tête, j'hésite entre cette hache et cette épée.
La hache c'est plus sûr.
Mais l'épée ça ferait joli.
Aelys ?
Quoi ?
Je peux te parler ?
Ouais ?
Est-ce que tu penses que la mort est la meilleure solution pour Belyr ?
Oh ouais, je te vois venir.
Tu vas faire...
"Oh non, le pauvre, épargnons-le".
Il m'a planté un couteau dans le dos !
Alors déjà, je parle pas comme ça.
Puis alors, épargner Belyr ?
Non, pas du tout.
Non, non, non.
Je cherche quelque chose de pire, pour lui, que la mort.
Parce que la mort, finalement, c'est gentil.
Voire, un peu vulgaire.
La mort c'est gentil et vulgaire ?
Qu'est-ce qui est pire que la mort ?
Cette discussion ?
Oh non ! La torture !
Mais oui, la torture !
Mais évidemment ! Avec un couteau.
Non, non.
Les petits couteaux de pêcheur là.
Qu'est ce qu'ils sont crades ceux-là.
Tout le temps plein de terre.
- C'est pas ça, non.
Il s'ouvrirait là et y ferait...
"Aïe, j'ai super mal".
Non, non, non, la torture c'est pas pire que la mort.
Parce que c'est Belyr, il est faible, donc il va mourir tout de suite.
Donc c'est pas intéressant.
Alors que si tu allonges sa peine...
Si tu la fais durer des semaines...
Voire, des mois...
Tu peux profiter de ta vengeance pendant très longtemps.
Et c'est quoi ton plan ?
L'exile.
L'endroit où y a les fous ?
Non, ça c'est l'asile.
Non, l'exile.
Tu le chasses du château.
Tu le fais partir loin, loin, loin.
Tu le dépossèdes de tout.
Tu le mets genre... paysan.
Et tu le regardes se débattre.
Comme tu l'as pas tué, les gens pensent que tu es un bon roi.
Et toi...
Tu peux te venger en t'amusant.
C'est ludique.
Wow... t'es diabolique !
Paysan... C'est bon ça !
Il aurait un chapeau moche ?
Ouais.
Les pieds tout crades ?
Pourquoi pas.
Il serait dans un champ ?
Grave.
Il saurait pas quoi faire ?
Ouais.
Du coup il bêcherait.
Après il ferait "to-to-to-to ah mon dos !".
"Oh, il doit pleuvoir".
Par exemple.
J'adore.
On fait ça.
Alors, bah c'est très humide...
Ça sent vraiment mauvais.
En fait, moi quand je suis arrivé, je pensais que c'était les toilettes des chevaux.
Mais non, non, non. C'est le lieu de vie.
Puis les toilettes bah...
Les toilettes...
Belyr ?
La soupe d'ortie au poivre est prête.
J'arrive compagnon !
C'est les potes du cachot.
Une nouvelle vie commence.
T'as mis trop de temps, trop tard, y en a plus !
C'est trop tard pour demander la mort ?